[Applause]
[Applause]
it's so great to meet you guys
congratulations on the ninth ep talk to
me about the title what does that
represent
[Music]
well let's talk about that single rock
with you
[Music]
with this song you're showing your fans
a different side of you how does it feel
to explore like the rock star side of 17
there are a lot of contributions from a
lot of the members of the group in this
mini album um why was it important for
you guys to not only sing on this record
but also to write and compose it too
much
foreign
i love it so i feel like the reward here
is that you get to see through your own
art from start to finish but what would
you say is the biggest challenge about
self-producing your own music
[Music]
so talk to me about your first ever
english single two minus one what is the
song about and also why was now the time
to do a english only song
so two minus one it's a pop punk track
and
it's about um acting cool acting like i
don't miss
my ex-lover but in truth
i do
that's yeah that's what it's really
about and
um we just wanted to make an english
track and right um hopefully this is
this song would be the start for 17.
so we me and josh the two of us started
yeah start the english track
marathon so you want to do more english
tracks
definitely yeah it was like a very new
thing for us but
yeah it just came out really great and
we're really really excited to release
more
english singles or albums yeah well i'll
tell you this based on what i know so
far about two minus one i can relate to
that song so thank you for writing
saying that you're you're okay when
you're not
so you want the person to know that
you're okay but you're actually not
right oh my god listen that's my been my
whole year listen
here speaking of messages what message
do you hope your fans
foreign
oh
and finally what's next for 17 will you
guys be going on tour will you be
hitting the road
um
foreign
[Music]
you